ACCIDENTALLY RELEASED FROM THE
WUHAN LAB.
SEAN.
>> Sean: TRACE GALLAGHER,
THANK YOU FOR THAT REPORT.
EVEN MORE TROUBLING DEVELOP HIS
TONIGHT SURROUNDING CHINA AS
WHITE HOUSE ADVISOR PETER
NAVARRO REVEALS THAT CHINA HAS
BEEN CAUGHT CORNERING THE MARKET
FOUR TEAM MEDICAL SURPRISE.
NOT ONLY THAT, DRONES BEING
DEPLOYED TO SURVEILLED AMERICANS
AMID LOCKDOWN ORDERS ACTUALLY
COME FROM A COMPANY WITH TIES TO
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT.
WHILE MATT, I WONDER IF THEY’RE
MAKING MONEY OFF OF THAT TOO.
INTERESTING QUESTION, RIGHT?
I WAS PREVIOUSLY SUSPECTED BY
THE WAY, OF SPYING ON U.S.
CITIZENS.
G.O.P. LAWMAKERS LIKE
SENATOR TOM COTTON, CONGRESSMAN
CRENSHAW, THEY ARE CALLING OUT
BEIJING LIES, DECEIT.
THEY HAVE INTRODUCED A BILL THAT
WOULD ALLOW AMERICANS TO HOLD
CHINA ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
VIRUS RESPONSE FAILURES AND OF
COURSE, THE DEMOCRATS, THEIR
ALLIES, STATE RUN TV, MEDIA MOB,
THEY CONTINUE TO SPEND FOR
CHINA, SHOCKER.
HERE WITH REACTION,
SENATOR TOM COTTON.
CONGRESSMAN DAN CRENSHAW, ALSO
OF "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
BEST SELLER FORTITUDE.
GOOD TO SEE YOU BOTH.
CONGRESSMAN, YOU HAVEN’T BEEN ON
IN A WHILE, LET ME ASK YOU ABOUT
YOUR SUIT.
AND TO ME, THE MOST REVEALING
AND DASTARDLY EVIL THING THAT
THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT DID --
OH, THEY SAW HOW BAD WUHAN
PROVINCE WAS, SO THEY CUT ALL
TRAVEL TO AND FROM WUHAN FROM
WITHIN CHINA BUT THEY LET THE
PLANES GOT INTERNATIONALLY, HOW
NICE IS THAT?
>> EXACTLY.
5 MILLION PEOPLE LEFT WUHAN.
IF THEY ALLOWED THIS VIRUS TO
SPREAD.
THEY KNEW IT WOULD SPREAD, THEY
SPREAD’S FALSE TALKING POINTS
LIKE IT WON’T SPREAD FROM HUMAN
TO HUMAN CONTACT.
THEY DIDN’T LET SCIENTISTS INTO
INVESTIGATE.
THEY ACTUALLY DISAPPEARED
DOCTORS WHO TRY TO BLOW THE
WHISTLE.
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS AND
INFECTIONS THEY HAD.
WHEN WE DROPPED THIS BILL LAST
FRIDAY, THAT WAS THE SAME DAY
THAT THE CHINESE GOVERNMENT SAID
WE UNDERESTIMATED BY ABOUT 50%
THE NUMBER OF DEATHS.
THEY DIDN’T UNDERESTIMATE, THEY
KNEW THIS IS CHINA, THEY’D KEEP
TRACK OF EVERY SINGLE PERSON.
OF COURSE THEY KNEW.
NOW WE KNOW HOW THEY HAVE
WRONGED US, AMERICANS ARE GOING
TO DO WHAT AMERICANS DO WHEN WE
FEEL AN INJUSTICE IS LEVELED
AGAINST US, WE’RE GOING TO FIND
SOME BUDDY TO SUE.
GO AHEAD.
>> Sean: OKAY, TRUE.
BUT I’LL TELL YOU WHAT, WE ALSO
HAVE SOMETHING ELSE.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF OUR DEBT.
THIS IS COSTING THIS COUNTRY,
SENATOR COTTON, 4.
I’D SAY THEY OUGHT TO FORGIVE
THAT DEBT AS IT RELATES TO THE
COST OF ALL OF THEIR MASS THAT
THEY CAUSE.
>> YEAH, SEAN, YOU AND DAN HAD
SOME GOOD POINTS THERE ABOUT THE
EVIL INTENT OF CHINESE LEADERS.
POTENTIALLY ALLOWING THEM
OUTSIDE THEIR BORDER.
HE ALSO MENTIONED THE THWARTING
OF PERSONAL PROTECTION
EQUIPMENT, TRYING TO PROFITEER
OFFERED, OR EVEN CHINESE DRONES
TO COLLECT INFORMATION.
CHINA HAS TO PAY FOR ALL OF
THIS.
ONE WAY TO PAY AS THE LAWSUIT OR
THE LAW THAT DAN AND I HAVE
INTRODUCED WOULD BE TO ALLOW
AMERICAN COURTS TO HEAR CASES
AGAINST CHINA’S LEADERS.
ANOTHER ONE TO BE CONSIDERED,
ALL THAT DEBT THAT CHINA
CURRENTLY HOLDS, GIVEN THE FACT
THAT WE’RE GOING TO HAVE TO
DEFICIT FINANCE SO MUCH OF THE
MONEY THAT WE ARE SPENDING TO
HELP FLOAT OUR BUSINESSES AND
HELP OUR DISTRESS --
>> Sean: WHY CAN’T WE GET
THIS --
>> ALSO CONSIDERED THINGS LIKE
SANCTIONS AGAINST CHINESE
OFFICIALS.
>> Sean: WHY CAN’T WE GET THE
PPP MONEY FAST?
WHY CAN’T WE -- THEY TRY TO
CHANGE ELECTION LAWS,
IMMIGRATION WAS, THEY WANT THE
ARTS AND HUMANITIES IN THE
KENNEDY CENTER, WHY CAN’T WE
PASS CLEAN BILLS, HELP AMERICAN
WORKERS ON THE BUSINESSES AND
HOSPITALS, PERIOD AND THEN NOT
SPEND ANY MORE MONEY?
>> IT SEEMS LIKE THE DEMOCRATS
JUST DON’T WANT TO TAKE YES FOR
AN ANSWER HERE.
WITH BEEN WILLING TO SUPPORT OUR
HOSPITALS, SUPPORT OUR SMALL
BUSINESSES AND OUR FAMILIES ALL
ALONG IN THE DEMOCRATS KEEP COME
AS YOU SAY --
>> Sean: WHAT DOES
NANCY PELOSI WANT NOW?
GATED MANSION, DOES SHE WANT
MORE ICE CREAM?
I WILL CENTER ALL THE ICE COME,
SHE CAN GET ON A PRIVATE JET AND
FLY BACK TO WASHINGTON SAFELY,
LEAF OR MILLION-DOLLAR GATED
MANSION AND I WILL BUY HER A
FREEZER AND I WILL FILL IT WITH
ICE CREAM, CONGRESSMAN.
>> IT’S INFURIATING.
WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN IN
WASHINGTON A WEEK AGO HAVING A
NONCONTROVERSIAL VOTE TO SIMPLY
REPLENISH THE PPP FUNDING.
WE ALL KNOW THAT.
IF YOU KNOW WHAT THEY DO, SEAN?
BECAUSE THE MAINSTREAM MEDIA
LETS THEM GET AWAY WITH IT.
THE LEFT-WING MEDIA ALLOWS THEM
TO DO IT AND SO THEY DON’T TELL
PEOPLE WHAT’S ACTUALLY
HAPPENING, SO THEIR SUPPORTERS
SIMPLY SAY, OH, THEY MEAN WELL,
THEY MUST HAVE A GOOD REASON.
THEY DON’T, THERE IS NO OTHER
SIDE TO THIS AND IT’S REALLY
GROSS.
>> Sean: THE SENATE SHOULD
STAY IN SESSION.
HAVE A VOTE EVERY DAY.
KEVIN McCARTHY, BRING THE
REPUBLICANS BACK.